في صحيفه لوموند يتناول تقرير ما سماه
معضله الانفاق التي تواجهها اسرائيل وتضيق
الخناق على جيشها قائلا ان دخول الانفاق
يتطلب انخراط القوات الاسرائيليه في صراع
طويل الامد اكثر خطوره من حرب المدن
والفشل في استكشافها يترك لحماس امكانيه
تطوير قواتها من جديد وتنفيذ هجمات جديده
خلص التقرير الى ان حماس اتقنت بناء الفخ
خلال 20 عاما في ارتس مقال لا يجد وسيله
لتفسير سلوك اسرائيل في غزه موضحا ان
تبرير الدمار والقتل والمجاعه والحصار من
خلال الدعايه الاسرائيليه لم يعد ممكنا
يلفت المقال الى ان اي ضيف رسمي يصل الى
اسرائيل يضطر الى المرور عبر كيبوتس بئري
واذا تجرا ونظر الى قطاع غزه فسيتم بانه
معاد للساميه حسب المقال الهاسب
الاسرائيليه خدعه ولا تحكي القصه الحقيقيه
الكامله في صحيفه الجارديان يرى تقرير ان
الحرب في غزه كلما طالت زاد خطر سوء
التقدير والتصعيد الاقليمي الذي تخشى
اداره بايدن ان يجر ايران الى صراع اوسع
يذكر التقرير ان واشنطن وباريس تقودان
مفاوضات سريه للتهدئه مع حزب الله لكنه
يستبعد امكانيه اقناعه بابعاد قواته عن
بلدات جنوب لبنان التي يستمد منها الدعم
الشعبي التقرير ينقل عن دبلوماسي اوروبي
قوله ان التقديرات تشير الى ان التصعيد
اصبح اكثر
احتمالا مجله فورين بوليسي نشرت مقالا جاء
فيه ان حجم المعاناه الانسانيه التي سببها
الرد العسكري الاسرائيلي المدمر على هجوم
حماس صدم قطاعا واسعا من العالم لكن بايدن
اختار توريط الولايات المتحده في حرب كبرى
نهايتها غامضه والنصر في فيها غير
مؤكد كتب المقال ان بايدن صور حربي
اوكرانيا واسرائيل على انهما صراع بين
الديمقراطيه والاستبداد ومع ذلك لا يبدو
خطابه مقنعا
للجميع نقرا في موقع المونتر ان المجاعه
تهدد سكان غزه بينما يتواصل القصف
الاسرائيلي ابرز الموقع تحذيرات وكالات
الاغاثه من ان الوضع يزداد سوءا في غزه
بمرور الوقت من حيث قله الغذاء والمياه
الصالحه للشرب ونقل الموقع قول توماس وايت
مدير شؤون اونروا في غزه ان كل يوم يمر
على سكان القطاع هو صراع من اجل البقاء
والعثور على الطعام
والماء